[Music]
welcome everybody to the interval at the
long
now my name is mck Kara and I am the
director of development here um thank
you everybody for being here thank you
for being on the live stream special
thanks to our long now members I now
have the pleasure of introducing our
speaker for the evening KOCO Crum is an
applied mathematician and a writer she
has worked in the deep end of the theory
and practice of optimization from MIT to
Silicon Valley and she now lives on a
remote island um in the Pacific
Northwest Koko will take us on a journey
through optimization its rise to
dominance and its enduring myth and ask
the question and and answer that uh as
well how a mathematical idea became such
a
prominent characterizing idea of our
relationship with uh each other and and
with the natural world welcome
[Applause]
Coco I'm so happy to be here um both at
the long now which is just a fantastic
organization and a fantastic space and
in San Francisco in general I wanted to
to start with a definition of
optimization there are a lot of ways to
to Define it in the book I talk about it
both as a mathematical concept but also
as a gospel or a philosophy that
underlies a lot of our social lives but
I've sort of boiled it down to
optimization is a set of constraints or
parameters an objective function which
is what you're optimizing for and a
search process which lets you search
within those constraints in order to
find the best as you've defined it with
the the objective function I give this
example of making lemonade right how do
we find the best of all possible
lemonades and it turns out that that's a
you know on its face is a seemingly
simple question but you might Define the
best lemonade in in different ways right
it might be
something that's sweet it might be
something that's tart it you know if
you're in a hot climate you might want
it more watered down and similarly there
they're going to be different
constraints and parameters based on
where you're making this lemonade are
are lemons really expensive are they
cheap do other things count as lemonade
like strawberry lemonade or is that kind
of cheating something that's you know
that I I keep returning to
is that often times when we seek Alterna
alternatives to to optimization we say
we're optimizing too much we might you
know suggest an alternative which is
like switching the the objective
function right so like this this isn't
the best lemonade we shouldn't be making
lemonade this way let's let's change the
objective function we should be making
tart lemonade instead of sweet you know
that's that's often an attractive way
out I think we see it often in in the
tech world like we've things are are
moving too fast we've scaled too much
we've optimized too much how can we de
optimize but the question is asked like
how can we change the objective function
to De optimize in an optimal way and I
think
that's um and I mean there there's so
many examples we can we can sort of Mock
and and laugh at um but it points to a a
a serious problem right which is that
this mindset has so overtaken our way of
seeing that even slowing down is
something we seek to do in an optimal
way so I'm going to refine the question
that Mo started with which is the
driving question of this book and sort
of what I've been thinking about for the
last decade or so which is how did
optimization this mathematical technical
concept take on such an outsize role in
our philosophies in our minds in our
day-to-day lives how did it in other
words become our modern gospel and one
of the things if you end up reading the
book is um that you'll find is that I
end up comparing it in many places to a
religion I travel around the country in
the early days of the pandemic to some
of what I call the shrines to
optimization that are kind of these
monuments to how we've made the world
more efficient and also what we've lost
and obviously or maybe not so obviously
coid and the early pandemic days brought
to the four some of the strengths as
well as some of the shortcomings of
optimization we saw Supply chains that
we once thought were infallible right we
could just click a button and the Amazon
truck would pull up and out would you
know Cascade our various packages from
all over the world within you know hours
that was no longer given the cheap food
we'd come to take for granted over the
last century and really the last 50
years in America I mean we've we have
in this day and age in this country some
of the cheapest food and the most
diverse food not necessarily the most
nutrient rich or dense food but um
certainly an an abund you know an unseen
abundance of food at unseemly low prices
that we've never seen in history so so
that be came into question as well right
as some food supply chains food growing
was disrupted
and um a lot of the cracks that had long
existed in those systems were brought to
the
FL so this is an example of one of the
places I visited in order to get to this
personal Journey that I was just talking
about in the middle of the field the
bulldozer pauses and out pops its driver
for a cigarette break it's a perfect
September Day in Northern Kentucky crisp
blue free a neighboring Dozer carves
antill ruts through the construction
site he is helping build the Amazon air
Hub a $1.5 billion site expected to host
some 100 cargo airplanes 300 trucks and
a robotic sort Center sprawling over a
million square feet slated to open in
2021 it's currently a mess of
construction equipment and
barricades As Americans moved more of
their shopping online at the onset of
the 2020 pandemic Amazon sales increased
some 40% the company's revenues grew by
a mindboggling $100 billion dollar an
efficiently scheduled Fleet of aircraft
will cut hours and days off already fast
delivery times if the North America
circulatory system conveys packages and
goods to its every extremity this corner
of Kentucky represents its antill heart
ups and DHL and Wayfair has distribution
centers here 65% of the population of
the United States lives within 600
square miles 1day drive or 90-minute
flight away it's close to five other
airports to Rail lines and rivers and
ports nearly 3 billion pounds of cargo
pass through the Cincinnati Northern
Kentucky International Airport annually
a number that continues to rise as
Amazon expands its Fleet something as
seemingly local as a main lobster might
be diverted West through Kentucky only
to be sent East again to an upscale
restaurant in New York the circulatory
system its trucks and airplanes and
conveyor belts and plastic bubble wrap
is kept in motion by a set of equations
and code this code tells each box where
to go and when in the most efficient way
undering all this is a set of
mathematical models that's explored each
possibility assigned probabilities and
planned contingencies and beneath this
set of models the hidden choreographer
is a way of looking at the
world so
that's that's what this book is about
something that's maybe not explicit in
this talk or in the book is that and but
perhaps goes without saying is
technology of optimization has given us
a huge number of gifts right we have the
exposure to different cultures we have
the ability to travel um because of
optimized you know engineered aircraft
and optimized Airline schedules um we do
have foods from around the world brought
to our doorsteps we don't you know not
all of us need to be Farmers as just a
few centuries ago you know a large
percent of the population needed to do
because we've optimized agriculture in
important ways this beautiful lady is
Marie condo
we're all or most of us are probably
familiar with Maria condo's brand of
minimalism and
decluttering and you know I really see
her as sort of the apotheosis of
optimization and that final bridge to
making it not just a philosophy but sort
of a a Lifestyle brand like a
consumerist thing you can sign on to and
and buy and connecting you know
taking what the utilitarians did one
step further by
connecting moral virtue to a way of
being in the world optimally um and and
to an improvement of society right it's
right there in her book's title the
life-changing magic of tidying up
tidying up is not just something you do
because it's the right thing to do but
it it because it will make you a better
person a more optimal person and it will
make Society better this is the section
I talk about about what we've lost with
optimization and not just what we've
gained this is a photo of Lake me which
was one of the huge you know along with
Lake Powell one of the huge water
projects of the early 20th century these
guys optimized for a particular levels
of water flow and rainfall based on a a
particular snapshot in time and what
they didn't do is
anticipate what might happen in the
future and you know not no through no
fault of their own right I think it's a
it's a natural human tendency when we
engineer we have to constrain the system
in a particular way we end up with
cities built on expectations of water
that are no longer there and really
difficult choices now in order to keep
systems of Agriculture and systems of
human
civilization with enough water these are
some airplane boneyards there are some
of the the Mojave Desert there's some in
Arizona there were all the giant jets go
to die a lot of
these out you know live their lifespans
some of them we just built Jets too big
and optimized for particular levels of
travel and then the the Jets had to be
taken out of out of service prematurely
because there just wasn't the the travel
to to justify them let's just say I have
a chapter on bison
too there's an asymmetry to optimizing
it's easier to optimize and in this case
it's a pretty brutal and um tragic
optimization I profile an Eastern Shon
man he's an ecologist who's working to
restore the Bison finding that what took
a decade or two to optimize is going to
take centuries um to
unwind so so how did we get here I talk
about how we got here in a couple of
ways one is how did we get here sort of
intellectually and the other is what are
the the components or the mathematical
Concepts or ideas that led to
optimization and in terms of how we got
here as a philosophical idea um I argue
that optimization it's you know it's
percolated into our mindsets in in most
of the west by now but it's a it's a
very uniquely American or Anglo kind of
concept it took root in this sort of
early Protestant ethos of of America and
it was brought to fruition by some
British thinkers including John Stewart
Mill who came up with this philosophy of
utilitarianism and what
utilitarianism says or or seeks to do is
to to create the greatest good or part
and parcel of that right is finding a
way to connect one's individual actions
to the greater good so that you're not
only kind of thinking what's morally
right or how should I best lead my life
but what which of my actions will be
best for society as a whole and this
kind of thinking was a hugely
important philosophical step in getting
to where we are we sort of bridging this
mathematical idea with what we see now
in our in our daily lives as a born and
bred Optimizer um I'm the child of many
generations of Engineers and you know
have studied these ideas and for a long
time you know been interested in maybe
not overtly personal optimization but
you know how to be the best I can be in
a particular context something I found
is that the opposite is much less
straightforward than
optimizing right um how do you step back
and step away from this how do you kind
of opt out of of the system that's not
as straightforward as it might seem you
know i' I've had these threads maybe not
of activist Rebellion but just sort of
personal preference like I'd rather walk
than take an Uber I'd rather have a flip
phone the more I time I spent here in
technology the the stronger this kind of
countercultural impulse grew I'll just
read a little bit about how that
happened so this is about
and I increasingly felt the fakeness in
all this abstraction of Silicon Valley
in trying to represent the lushness of a
field with green pixels on a satellite
map by contrast the general excitement
for the tools of optimization seemed
only to grow the more I felt this
fanaticism the more I disbelieved it
myself my disenchantment was grounded in
the excesses of the tech industry but it
didn't begin or end there there I
bemoaned the Yoke of corporate schedules
and resisted upgrading my old flip phone
for about a decade past the point of
embarrassment I began to contemplate on
the one hand how to escape Silicon
Valley and on the other how to destroy
it disenchanted and without any better
idea I started talking to people I found
myself wandering around first in the
agricultural Midwest and then all over
the country I met farmers and freight
brokers carpenters and Oil Workers as
soon as I could afford it I bought a
patch of land on a remote Northwestern
island with a rundown cabin and
endeavored to learn the skills necessary
to fix it up everyone I told in San
Francisco thought I was nuts we were at
the height of an incredible age they
reminded me not only that but what I did
was in high demand data science salaries
were through the roof I had the right
knowledge to make a mark what was I
doing rambling on about wellwater
testing and passive solar I don't
understand with your skills why you're
not flying around with billionaires and
private Jets right now a cousin
volunteered only half joking indeed as
my peers were spinning up data teams at
head fund and pharmaceutical companies I
was hanging out at Sugar beat factories
in North Dakota I still couldn't
pinpoint the locus of my dis
disillusionment but I knew it had to do
with the growing distance between my Two
Worlds the world represented by numbers
on computer screens and the world in
plain sight it wasn't until I moved into
the half-built cabin with a hole in the
subfloor and walls I needed to finish
and logs I needed to split in order to
keep the wood stove going that it really
hit home here I was fiddling away on my
laptop for some far off research group
that wanted a better way to model
Wildfire spread in California so it
could sell more Insurance to homeowners
then i' put the laptop away and Fiddle
with a faulty well pump or stuff walls
with the sheep's wool insulation I'd cut
it up in cardboard boxes from Oregon my
vegetable starts mostly faltered and I
slowly made friends in the community I
realized the skills that had brought me
here the skills that had put me at the
Pinnacle of this new belief system of
efficiency and optimization these
weren't the skills that would help me
now I'm just going to leave you guys
with a
couple kind of mini takeaways that we
can go into the Q&A with you know when
when we talk about ways forward um I
think one of
them
involves this rethinking or
re-remembering of first principles and
remembering some of the things we've
lost lost to optimization we've lost a
lot of particulars and specifics as
optimization has commoditized and
flattened and atomized our world and
we've also lost a sense of scale um of a
connection between part and whole and of
human scale as we kind of automate a lot
of the world so that's my first takeaway
is a a refining or an attempt to refine
some of these things that we've lost and
the second is you know something I
learned through the process of writing
this book and also you know stepping
away if not completely out of the the
tech World um is that there really isn't
such a thing as opting out especially in
this day and age right even where where
I live is plugged in as ever right
there's fast internet there's fast
delivery you know slightly slower but
fast delivery times um
and instead of framing it as kind of
opting out of optimization which is very
difficult to do unless you're truly
becoming a Hermit and and going
completely off grid I think what the
next era
involves is kind of an expansion rather
than a retraction of our or contraction
of our of our language and our way of
seeing and so I'll just end with this
very short that speaks to I think
think the difficulty of finding
alternatives to optimization but also
the necessity that that we do somehow
half a lifetime ago my sister said to me
exasperated stop being such an
Optimizer we were walking around a small
town somewhere when we didn't know well
with a few hours to kill and a couple
stops to make find a grocery store a
hardware shop a place for lunch it was
before smartphones and we had no map I
began plotting aloud possible paths to
maximize the chances we'd hit all of our
spots in as little time as possible she
then told me to shut up slow down and
relax she was right it was a sunny day
and we really had nothing to do Beyond
enjoying the weather and walk and
conversation there was no need for me to
optimize yet her intreaty left me
wondering what is the alternative to
optimizing it surely wasn't picking the
least optimal or the worst route nor was
it complete random Randomness clearly we
had some sense of direction and would
eventually stop somewhere for lunch
passing by a place if it looked really
bad going in if we were hungry and it
looked good nor was it some algorithmic
intermediate such as searching for X
number of minutes and then choosing the
next best place the alternative was
neither to embrace more optimization nor
to rebel against it it was quite simply
to drop the language of efficiency
entirely so
brilliant thank you Coco so I was
fascinated by the by the Dynamics of
optimization that you identify in the in
the real world and how because of these
self reinforcing dynamics of
optimization how difficult it is to back
out de optimize uh but but you also
Identify some kind of pockets of of
resistance uh to optimization like why
do you why do you think that is why do
you think the the power or the dominance
of optimization as a driving idea might
be
waning
so this is a great seg wve to John
Wayne um who I use it as as an example
of what I'm calling metaphoric breakdown
so I think that's the period we're in
where we have this metaphor of
optimization dominated our way of seeing
and the last five or six years and
especially with the pandemic years
really magnified the the cracks in that
way of seeing um so I think optimization
as a technology continues to serve Us in
so many ways um but as a way of seeing
it's starting to to break down and I use
the example of John Wayne and in
particular a movie the first movie so
John Wayne is this Paragon of you know
Western controlled masculinity right
he's the guy who always fights for good
in these cowboy movies that are very
moralistic right it's very clear there's
good there's bad and John Wayne is
clearly on the side of good right and
there's this one movie called the
Cowboys in which it's the first movie in
which John Wayne is killed on screen and
it was shocking to anybody who watched
it at the time um Roger eert said it it
violated the sacred convention of
western films right which is that the
bad guys never hit and the good guys
never never miss and never die um so I
think there's something akin to that
happening right now and you asked the
question why is it happening I think
we're starting to feel this this
disconnect and this lack of a you know
this this disconnect between the scale
that we're living at as humans and the
scale that optimization has enabled and
and given us thank you um I'll take one
from from the live stream uh probably
possibly quickly um but Justin Meers
asks um is is this not really just the
question of like can can the problems of
of that you identifi of optimization be
solved by just selecting what to
optimize for better I don't personally
think that they can because I think the
things that we've lost because of
optimization um are sort of lost outside
of the the frame of of optimization
itself and the more we entrench on that
frame by saying optimization is is how
we're going to solve it the more we
forget these things that are outside of
it so if somebody you know I I'm open
to hearing how that would work but the
examples of this kind of solutionism
that that I've seen have only led to
more
fragilities um more
alienation
and more loss of of our
Humanity excellent um yeah more audience
questions one over there
yeah I thank you for being here um I I
think you may have answered it a little
bit but is the issue optimization or is
the issue a narrow-minded and selfish
set of outcomes where a towards so is
there a way to still have
optimization but Encompass some of the
things you think were we've
lost yeah for sure um I think my
argument or the book is can be seen as
maybe more pessimistic than it is or or
than I am
um I
certainly think that the technology of
optimization and the way of seeing of
optimization of improvement and
Engineering right has led to amazing
things an amazing way of of seeing the
world I am simply arguing that it can't
be the only way and this is really again
not a call to opt out or to return to
some primitive state so much as
to allow back in other ways of seeing
that aren't
about improving and control and I think
control is really that shadow side of
improving and
maximizing I'll take one from the live
stream here um uh Curtis Mitchell asks
is is optimization not just the so
socioeconomic version of what nature
does for example Evolution optimizes for
reproduction or efficient metabolism I I
disagree with that actually because I
think that that's the human um lens on
what nature does right we like to see
nature in our own image and these
metaphors are very powerful right um we
see brains as working like computers and
and vice versa and I think these
metaphors can be very good right because
they do lead to new insights like the
theory of evolution may not have we may
not have come up with it if we hadn't
been seeing things in a in a particular
way or as potentially subject to to our
control I I do think the the natural
world if you look at how Evolution or or
how the natural world optimizes there
are some distinctions between how we
might optimize or engineer things as as
humans right there's a lot of Randomness
in how Evolution works there's a lot of
mistakes and when we work to engineer
systems we're we're trying as much as
possible to erase redundancies and erase
mistakes whereas nature kind of
preserves some of those redundancies
yeah yeah that definitely resonates we
have this idea of we we romant
romanticize nature as as very efficient
but it's it's the process of evolution
can be very very wasteful of course
Carter so you've so you've hinted at a
relationship between optimization and
thinking in terms of
solutions um and so I wonder what you
feel about the phrase or the idea of
solving climate change and and the
reason I'm giving that frame is that you
know a lot of optimization is involved
in that and even breaking out of the
idea of solving it which I personally
think is misguided or is a frame that's
really hard to break out of so I i'
wonder if you could expand a little bit
about solution how optimization
Solutions work and specifically how
maybe it relates to the question of
solving climate change react to that
yeah I mean I I think the way I think
about it and I write a little bit about
it in the book is like why have we it's
interesting to me that we've gotten to a
state where solving is the the framework
for it right um I don't you know I have
my opinions on whether that's that's
right or wrong but to me it's
interesting to to compare the
environmentalism of you know 50 or 100
years ago that in which which was
focused on
the or much more connected in terms of
cause and effect right and often you see
the the environmental problems that have
been most tractable for humans to so I
mean they're often human created
problems like acid rain or toxic
chemicals the ones that have proven most
tractable are are the ones um that are
less abstract and more connected and not
about solving this problem um that's
Global and humongous and very very
abstract right carbon dioxide is it's
invisible it's a concept right um
so I think it's interesting that we're
now in the state where where we do want
to solve it and solve it as a big
problem um
versus see it as sort
of resolving the the more local and
tractable impacts of our of our behavior
and our presence on the
environment thank you this has been a
fantastic discussion thank you very much
Coco like I mentioned we have Coco books
absolutely let's do it thank you give a
round of applause
to
[Applause]
[Music]